[موسيقى]
فرحه ولي العهد السعودي بفوز الاخضر
التاريخي تشعل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعيه
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي ماده دسيمه
للسخريه على السوشيال ميديا والكره تنطق
بالعربيه الزي الخليجيه ياسر قلوب جماهير
المونديال هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها
من العربيه رياضه واسعد
[موسيقى]
نبدا اخبارنا من صور الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد السعودي وهو يتابع المواجهه
التي دارت بين الاخضر ونظيره الارجنتيني
في مونديال قطر هذه الصور باتت اليوم
الاكثر تداوله في جميع منصات السوشيال
ميديا وخاصه فرحه ولي العهد السعودي بفوز
الاخضر التاريخي على التعليقات
انتشرت وبرز منها انها فرحه تمثل الوطن
التواصل الاجتماعي ايضا شهدت فرحه جنونيه
عاشتها الجماهير العربيه والسعوديه بعد
فوز الاخضر التاريخي على الارجنتينيه على
الارجنتين صاحبها في بعضها سخريه حيث
انتشر فيديو لاعب المنتخب السعودي اثناء
التوجه بسؤال لزميله علي بليه قائلا اين
ميسي ليرد عليه لا اعرف في اشاره الى
نجاحهم في السيطره على خطوره النجم
التانجو بعض انصار الاخضر
المنتخب التونسي ايضا استطاع ان يحقق رقم
الايجابيا لم يستطيع ان يصل اليه على مدار
44 عاما عقبت عدوله السلبي مع نظيره
الدنماركي في نهائيات كاس العالم 2022
ويلاحق منتخب نسور قرطاج حلم الترشح للدور
الثاني من نهائيات المونديال للمره الاولى
في تاريخهم بعد ان عاجز المنتخب التونسي
عن ذلك خلال مشاركته الموندياليه
رومانسيه
خطفت الاضواء الخليجيه حيث ابدا عدد كبير
من المشجعين سعادتهم بارتداء الثوب وشماغ
او ما يعرف بالدشداشه
المصورين في شوارع قطر خلال الساعات
الماضيه